hey 42 here there is a strange
unexplainable phenomenon that plagues
the stock market it's called the tink
High effect there is a huge and very
sudden drop in the stock market whenever
a film or television series starring
Hong Kong actor Adam Cheng is released
if this is a strangest thing you've ever
heard then you're not alone it may seem
completely crazy but it's true the stock
market is an enormous global beast that
constantly goes up or goes down and
which direction it will go in the future
is determined by millions of social
economic and political factors many of
the world's greatest mathematicians and
analysts has spent years attempting to
accurately predict the stock market all
have failed sudden drops in the markets
are usually caused by major news
releases the release of a new film or TV
show should have no impact whatsoever on
the markets yet despite this on the 5th
of October 1992 the first episode of a
TV series called the greed of man
starring Hong Kong actor Hutton Cheng
was aired on TV the Hang Seng Index
which measures the combined strength of
Hong Kong stock markets fell by 600
points and then two years later instinct
made its TV debut starring Adam Chang
the Hang Seng Index fell by over 2,000
points three years later Adam Chang
stars in Once Upon a Time in Shanghai
guess what the Hang Seng Index fell by
300 points this happened time and time
again over 25 years and many TV and film
releases every single time the stock
market unexplainably
dropped due to Adam Chang's appearance
instead shows this phenomenon have been
speculated upon by stock brokers for
decades not one has been able to explain
the true cause but some investors argue
that the first one or two occurrences
were genuine coincidences and it has
since become a self-fulfilling
prophecy when a great number of people
believe something to be true even if it
isn't they can actually make it happen
through their subsequent actions and so
due to the so called ting Chi effect
happening in the past now whenever a TV
show or film starring Adam Cheng is
released it becomes big news in Hong
Kong especially amongst financial
investors because financial investors
are expecting the stock market to drop
upon the show's release they could
actually be fulfilling this prophecy and
making it happen themselves through
their investments and thus a one-time
coincidence has be caught a regularly
occurring phenomenon due to crowd
psychology if you think a Chinese film
star buggering up the stock market is
strange you won't believe what I'm about
to tell you this tale of coincidence is
between two American presidents none
other than Abraham Lincoln and John F
Kennedy the timelines of their
individual lives are so unbelievably
similar to each other that many people
have a hard time believing it to be just
a coincidence firstly Abraham Lincoln
was elected to Congress in 1846 John F
Kennedy was elected to Congress in 1946
precisely 100 years later that Lincoln
was elected president in 1860 JFK was
elected president in 1960 again exactly
100 years apart then both presidents and
their wives lost their children whilst
living in the White House but it gets
even weirder both presidents were shot
in the head and both were shot dead on a
Friday
both men were shot in the back of the
head and in the presence of their wives
Lincoln was shot inside Ford's Theatre
and Kennedy was shot in a Lincoln car
made by Ford
when it comes to presidential
coincidences there's something very odd
going on with their hands 10% of the
global population are left-handed but
that figure is massively skewed when it
comes to US presidents 50 percent of the
previous 12 presidents were left-handed
that's five times higher than the norm
although there may be more to this than
pure coincidence some scientists believe
that left-handed people are more capable
of quicker and broader thinking this is
backed up by the fact that a much higher
percentage of historical geniuses
Einstein Isaac Newton and Charles Darwin
for example were left-handed when
compared to the general population but
there are some incredible stories of
coincidences from history that have no
logical explanation bermuda 1975 a man
is riding a moped down the street when
suddenly a taxi carrying a passenger
hits him at high speed he is killed
instantly exactly one year later the
dead man's brother is killed in the
exact same way and when I say the exact
same way I mean he was driving the same
moped not a similar moped the exact same
one he was struck down in the exact same
spot by the same taxi driver and get
this the taxi driver was carrying the
same passenger to top it off the
brothers were both 17 years old when
they died that's seriously spooky a man
named henry ziegland knew all too well
about coincidences in 1883 he broke up
with his girlfriend she was so upset by
this that she committed suicide
the girl's brother was so angry that he
hunted down ziegland and shot him in the
head the brother then immediately turned
the gun on himself and took his own life
unaware to the deceased brother his
bullet had not actually killed ziegland
it narrowly missed grazing his cheek and
lodged itself in a tree behind him the
bullet remained in that tree for many
years
till one day ziegland decided to chop
down the tree it was such a hardy tree
that ziegland had to turn to dynamite to
blow up the tree instead he blew the
tree to smithereens with a few sticks of
dynamite but the explosion propelled the
bullet from the tree straight into
Zealand's head killing him the very same
bullet that was meant for his head all
those years ago
unbelievable coincidences can sometimes
follow a single theme for example and
this is seriously weird it turns out
that lost precious rings have a long
history of turning up inside the bellies
of fish I've not lost it this is a
genuine thing in fact if you've lost
your wedding ring you'd be better off
going fishing than actually looking for
it accounts of this go all the way back
to 500 BC when the fierce tyrant of
Samos Polycrates threw his gold and
emerald seal ring into the sea then six
days later a fisherman brought a fish to
Polycrates door and presented it to him
whilst preparing the fish Polycrates
servants cut into it and what was inside
its belly none other than the very ring
that he had cast into the sea a week ago
an incredible coincidence indeed but
this could be no more than an urban
legend
it was 2,500 years ago after all but the
same remarkable coincidence has repeated
itself in recent years two tales come
from Norway the first tells of a man
called Waldemar Andersen whilst fishing
in the North Sea he caught a large card
and brought it home to prepare for
dinner
he cut opened the Cod's stomach to find
a gold earring inside it he gave it to
his wife who was shocked she knew
instantly that it was the earring that
she had lost a week earlier when it had
fallen into the sea there are plenty
more fish in the sea but to catched a
very one that contains your wife's lost
earring he's nothing short of amazing so
then what if I told you this second
story also in Norway took place not over
one week but ten years in 1979 Robert
Johansen aged 50 who is fishing in a
norwegian fjord like her last tale he
caught a large cot that would be fitting
for his family's dinner that evening his
grandmother prepared the fish back at
home and in the fish's stomach none
other than a diamond ring the
grandmother instantly recognized it for
it was the same valuable family heirloom
that she had lost in the fears over ten
years ago and there's more John Cross of
Virginia lost his ring in 1980 during a
vicious storm two years later he found
this inside a fish served up to him as
his favorite restaurant in
Charlottesville seriously why do people
keep finding their lost jewelry inside
fish
well how about I explain exactly how in
just a moment but first one last
remarkable story the chances of you
dying on a ship are extremely low but if
your name is Hugh Williams then it seems
your chances of perishing at sea are
near impossible on December the 5th 1660
for a ship sank in the Menai Strait off
the coast of Wales all 81 passengers on
board died except one man named Hugh
Williams then on December the 5th of
1785 another ship sank in the Menai
Strait
killing all 60 people on board except
one man named Hugh Williams then again
on December the 5th 1820 a third ship
guess where it sank the Menai Strait 25
people drowned and guess who was the
only survivor Hugh Williams
if that's not enough to float your
coincidental boats then get this on the
10th of July 1940 a British trawler was
destroyed by a German mine only two men
survived the catastrophe
both were named Hugh Williams
coincidence seems to favor misfortune
and nothing exemplifies this more than
the fact that five of the world's most
infamous leaders worst dictators and
genocidal maniacs to have ever lived
Adolphe Hitler Joseph Stalin Leon
Trotsky Tito and Sigmund Freud all share
something in common a very very eerie
coincidence indeed all five men lived in
Vienna at the exact same time before
they all became well known they all
walked through the same park every day
and regularly drank at the same coffee
shop the five men didn't know each other
before moving to or spending time in
Vienna some of the men even met whilst
in Vienna and together hatched their
ambitious plans to revolutionize the
world in their own image but these are
the five men who collectively changed
the history of Europe and arguably the
world more than anyone before them after
thousands of cities in Europe what are
the chances of them all residing in the
same city and frequenting the same
coffee shop what are the chances of five
sole survivors in shipwrecks in the same
location on the same day of the same
month being called the same name and for
goodness sake what are the chances of
numerous people finding their lost
jewelry inside fish what are the chances
that a man will be hit in the head by a
bullet flying from an explosion of a
tree the same bullet shot at his head
many years ago what are the chances that
numerous presidents share so many very
close similarities and we all want to
know what are the chances of a Chinese
man disrupting the stock market with his
acting well very high in fact
the chances of each of these apparently
highly unlikely events happening to you
is minutely small but the chance of it
happening to someone in the world is
very very high indeed almost 100% in
fact we've all heard of the law of large
numbers but Harvard mathematicians persi
diaconis and Fred mostella
created a new law called the law of
truly large numbers which states that
given a sample size large enough any
outrageous and unimaginable thing is
highly likely to happen despite how
unbelievable it may be just like how the
Infinite Monkey theorem states that a
roomful of monkeys randomly hitting keys
on typewriters will give in long enough
eventually type out the complete works
of William Shakespeare we don't find
likely everyday events particularly
remarkable quite the opposite we ignore
them but we do highlight unlikely
occurrences making them seem inherently
more remarkable say you're running a
simulation where the chance of a
particular event occurring is 0.1%
therefore the probability that is highly
unlikely event will not happen is 99.9%
but if you repeated the simulation 1,000
times the chance that the event will not
happen at least once is 0.999 into the
power of a thousand or 36.8% and that
means that the chance of the event
occurring once in a thousand simulations
is now 63.2% quite a bit different from
0.1 isn't it run the simulation 10,000
times and the chance of that unlikely
event happening is now 99.995%
if two omnipotent mice are to be
believed then planet Earth is one giant
simulation and there are over 7 billion
participants running their own
simulations everyday by simply living
out their lives the chance of something
truly remarkable and highly coincidental
happening among 7 billion people's lives
is almost 100 percent given a large
enough sample set ie the human race
anything that can happen will happen
eventually but of course when these very
special and seemingly miraculous events
do occur they get global media attention
giving them a very high level of
recognition yet we pay no attention to
the billions of uneventful things that
happen around the world every day
roughly 7 billion fish are caught from
the whales every day by humans and
probably not one of them contains
somebody's missing ring today but when
you think about the sheer scale of the
world and its inhabitants and all the
trillions of things that they
collectively do each day the fact that
someone didn't find their lost diamond
ring inside a fish today
never mind the past year actually seems
more unbelievable than if somebody did
thanks for watching if by some amazing
coincidence you enjoyed this video then
click here to support me on patreon
becoming a patron helps me to make
better videos and you can get some cool
rewards click here to watch another
video and if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe for more